quarante secondes c'est le temps qu'il a
fallu à matschiner à sa famille pour
s'extirper de leur maison située à
quelques mètres du port de beyrouth où a
eu lieu l'explosion
elle est aujourd'hui totalement en ruine
je suis sorti et j'ai vu que tous mes
frères étaient là il était très inquiet
parce qu'ils ne comprenaient pas ce qui
se passait ni quoi faire je leur ai
demandé de venir à l'intérieur et je
suis resté dehors pour voir ce qui se
passait car j'ai vu mes voisins courir
je suis allé avec eux et trente ou
quarante secondes plus tard il ya eu une
explosion
ma jambe c'est nier mais je m'inquiétais
tellement de ce qui pouvait arriver à
mes enfants et à ma famille qu'à ce
moment là je ne sentais rien je suis
vite rentrer chez moi pour voir si ça
allait bien
ma famille est composée de 15 personnes
et nous vivons tous dans la même maison
quand je suis entré dans la maison j'ai
vu que ma nièce était couvert de sang
en quelques minutes plus tard je suis
sorti et j'ai vu que les gens étaient
tous couverts de sang eux aussi
la maison a été rasé et je me suis
retrouvé sans abri à quelques pâtés de
maison de l'art c'est le même récit et
la même stupeur chez jal quand
l'explosion s'est produite mon père est
tombé par terre sachant que nous étions
chez nous à ce moment là un ami de mon
père est rapidement venus à notre aide
à son arrivée il a vu que notre maison
avait été détruite et mon père tout
couvert de sang n'arrivais pas à
respirer
il l'a soulevée et s'est mise à crier au
secours tout ce que je veux c'est que
mon père survivre et reviennent parmi
nous l'explosion a ravagé deux vastes
zones de beyrouth et de sa banlieue
partout des décombres jonchent le sol et
sont devenus le terrain de jeu macabre
des enfants quand j'ai entendu la
détonation
j'ai eu peur et je me suis mise à
pleurer
le bâtiment s'est effondré et les
escaliers aussi d'après une source de
sécurité libanaise
l'explosion a provoqué un cratère de 43
mètres de profondeur autre indicateur de
l'ampleur de la déflagration
l'institut américain de géophysique a
indiqué que ces capteurs ont enregistré
un séisme de 3 points 3 sur l'échelle de
richter mardi à beyrouth